une très jolie à première vue voici des
vêtements tout à fait normes
mais si l'on diminue l'intensité de
l'éclairage la féerie s'opèrent les
vêtements diffuse de la lumière
[Musique]
révolution pour le bien-être et en
direct de pékin voici la fibre
biochimiques dont des micro éléments ont
été projetés micro éléments qui
stimulent la circulation du sang et de
métabolisme cema des lions peuvent
adoucir la douleur et la fatigue en
muscles comme le stress d'un tee shirt
il est passé du triolet vitrail au lait
donc les uv a et les uvb et surtout les
uv elle puisque les uvb sont nocifs et
c'est super mais de les bloquer au
maximum deuxième test avec un verre de
vin le monsieur est toujours aussi
maladroit
aucune tâche apparemment ça a marché
ces micro billes que vous voyez ici sous
leur véritable apparence contiennent en
fait des mini doses cosmétiques des
produits qui agissent sur la peau comme
une crème hydratante ou bien un gel
tonifiant seule différence pour
appliquer la substance madame il vous
suffit d'enfiler une paire de collants
si deux jours cette parure et comme les
autres dans l'obscurité surprise les
dessous près d'un aspect magique partie
de cache-cache plockyn impossible donc
je vais vous montrer je peux mettre mon
portable à l'intérieur de ce textile
refermons bien vous voyez les petites
barrettes qui indique la capacité des
d'émettre et de recevoir s'arrêtent
instantanément lorsque je mets ce
textile autour
[Musique]